le nouveau jury de the voice alors vous
avez enquêté puisque concernant the
voice qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec
l'ancien jury est déjà et la question
est ce que vous trouvez le nouveau jury
plus fort que l'ancien vous répondez
chez vous et vous nous dites aussi ici
valérie benaïm d'abord il faut savoir
que y avait une volonté de la part de la
production
mais d'après mes sources de une sorte de
petit ras-le-bol il avait envie d'un peu
de bousculer tout ça et de
éventuellement changer les membres du
jury dont ils ont fait une bonne saison
de l'arrivée c'est vrai que c'est aussi
sa chute et voilà j'ai vu des audiences
il avait un petit peu envie de changer
tout ça et donc ils ont donc selon nous
pousser quelques uns gentiment ils
n'auront pas dit ouvertement
on a envie que tu dégages mais ils
auront fait comprendre que s'il voulait
aller voir ailleurs c'était plutôt pas
mal notamment en asie avec deux trois
chroniques il y avait quelques petites
tensions entre pagny et et tf1 pour
obispo c'est plus compliqué c'est plus
dans le flou moi je trouve qu'ils font
une erreur de laisser pascal tepa
excellent elle est en fait non mais
c'est vrai et alors il avait très envie
d'avoir un allouagne roi attention fait
une proposition et simplement elle
pouvait pas elle ne pouvait pas venir
mais elle même avait très envie aussi de
dire oui mais pour des raisons d'emploi
du temps finalement il sait elle n'est
fait sur était une bonne idée aussi elle
le fera elle fera un crochet par là vous
avez des infos si benjamin castaldi
voudrait que le jury est moins fort que
l'ancien c'est pour ça qu'on fait
d'accord à ce que la très bonne idée ses
sauces et soprano le retour de jennifer
aussi julien clay à moi c'est ça la
ménagère l'adorent l'aménageur oui la
ménagère voilà après la gère pour
florent pagny je cours je crois savoir
qu en fait mais la mémère désert non non
il est très beau je m'y intéresse toi
mais je fais ma mère à l'écouté du
nucléaire est maintenant bien sûr donc
donc est en fait sur florent pagny je
pense que et je pense avoir ma vie qui
les jugent très fâché suite à la
diffusion de reportages dans sept à huit
cents cet avis tout on a reparlé une
énième fois de ces de son exil fiscal
c'est pour ça qu'il est parti sans le
rec à cause de ça entre autres il est
créé la porte de tf1 est pour et pour
pascal je crois savoir que parce qu'elle
lui voulait rester ouais ils sont faits
moi je pense qu'ils ont fait une erreur
de lâcher bref en gros c'est grand bien
vous pensez que le nouveau souri et -
forge pas d'accord là aussi c'est une
calamité
entendu ce qu'ils avaient ri c'est cyril
arrêté c'est que plus personne ne veut
venir
soprano c'est le plus grande j'étais sûr
vous alliez dire sa plus grande crise du
moment qu'il ya que soprano et alors tu
me fait râler génial mika finissent tard
à thalassa et juniac certes c'est un des
plus grands artis et les tirs étaient
géniales jennifer il l'aurait pas les
interroger à clairac et plus personne ne
sait qui c'est julia vérité c'est une
émission est complètement des plages
ce sera la dernière